the table gives selected values of the
differentiable function f alright can we
use a mean value theorem to say that
there is a value C such that F prime of
C is equal to 5 and C is between 4 & 6
if so right of justification well it
meets to meet the to use the mean value
theorem you have to be differentiable
over the open interval and continuous
over the closed interval so it seems
like we've met that because if you're
differentiable over an interval you're
definitely can continuous over that
interval that's saying that's just a
generally differentiable function f I
guess over any interval but the next
part is to say alright but if that
condition is met then the slope of the
secant line between 4 comma F of 4 and 6
comma f of 6 that sum at least one point
in between 4 & 6 will have a derivative
that is equal to the slope of the secant
line and so let's figure out what the
slope of the secant line is between 4
comma F of 4 and 6 comma f of 6 and if
it's equal to 5 then we could use the
mean value theorem if it's not equal to
5 then the mean value theorem would not
apply and so let's do that F of 6 minus
F of 4 all of that over 6 minus 4 is
equal to 7 minus 3 over 2 which is equal
to 2 so 2 not equal to 5 so mean value
theorem doesn't apply alright let's put
an exclamation mark there from mark
there for emphasis
I let's do the next part can we use the
mean value theorem to say that the
equation F prime of X is equal to
negative 1 has a solution and now the
interval is from 0 to 2 if so write a
justification all right so let's see
this so if we were to take the slope of
the secant line so f of 2 minus f of 0
all that over 2 minus 0 this is equal to
negative 2 minus 0 all of that over 2
which is equal to negative 2 over 2
which is equal to negative 1 and so and
we also know that we meet the continuity
and differentiability conditions and so
we could say and since F is generally
just French
differentiable generally differentiable
differentiable it will be differentiable
differentiable and and continuous over
the interval from zero to two and I say
the close interval you just have to be
differentiable over the open interval
but it's even better I guess if you're
differentiable over the closed interval
cuz you have to be continuous over the
closed interval and so and since F is
generally differentiable it will be
differentiable and continuous over zero
too so the mean value theorem tells us
tells us that there is an X in that
interval from zero to two such that F
prime of X is equal to that secant slope
or you could say that average rate of
change is equal to negative one and so I
could write yes yes and then this would
be my justification this is the slope of
the secant line or the average rate of
change and since F is generally
differentiable it will be differentiable
and continuous over the closed interval
so the mean value theorem tells us that
there is an X in this interval such that
f prime of X is equal to negative one
and we're done